[Música]
essa é uma história como várias outras
naquela que as preta da periferia sempre
ouviram no dia a dia seja no gama noval
na santa essa história de várias
mulheres que assim como eu
no cerrado quente nasceu brasília terra
dos sonhos nem jada para além dos
escombros dívida externa mais um tombo
ninguém comenta a ditadura que foi
anunciado há cinco anos antes logo
depois dos meus avós caírem na estrada
pau de arara
nessa levada quantos dos nossos saíram
do nordeste pro meio do cerrado quadrado
no game moro no avião já o meu avô é
jogada para as camadas mais afastadas
daquela de 50km de busão talvez a
banalidade de brasília seja a nossa sina
do pobre que sai todo dia da satélite
pouco se lembra dos índios que morreram
no noroeste a 10 minutos daqui e assim
podemos refletir artes visuais
arquitetura não funcionais feitos para
pobre ver de longe no busão na janela
que ser novidade não embaixo fortaleceu
a quebrada contra a burguesia dá asco
não seria o patrimônio tombado mais um
fato que cala boca do espaço das pastas
onde morreram os soldados não
capitão-do-mato mais do capital o sonho
condicionado explorado pelo branco que
não importa se você passar mal
meu avô e minha avó casal interracial
quando filho estiveram contando com os
que morreram creio que oito infinidade
de possibilidades que o quadrado traria
só tinham arroz e farinha o sonho era
acompanhamento com ovo sinais elevados
mais velhos não tivesse morrido não sei
quem são não só um mito ninguém se
importa ea filha mais nova minha mãe
nascida sob ditadura uma das mulheres
mais duras que conheci na labuta ser
entre várias várias várias várias várias
várias várias várias aspas considerada
normal
mas assim como eu mulher de pitt pau foi
jogada para abate e nessa vibe bastou
uma injeção para ficar nove anos em
falar e se andar a injeção errada que
nessa levada causou paralisia infantil
tiro na autoestima de uma criança preta
tipo de genocídio no fuzil e atinjam não
tem lei não tem brasília não tem
cidadania para quem é pobre de periferia
se você recupera fisioterapia mas era
pobre ou pegava abusam do
é uma brasa norte para botar pra poder
fortalecer as sequelas da falha da perna
que os médicos do governo usaram errar
eu ficava em casa para fortalecer o
financeiro não tem jeito
mais uma família para centrada no gueto
sentindo as mazelas da colonização no
peito pra poder estudar teve que lutar
contra o machismo eo patriarcado já que
meu avô mas o macho achava que mulher
como ela não seria capaz de representar
hoje seu joelho é preto de tantas quedas
de descidas e subidas no gueto expressão
máxima de resistência mas uma mulher
periférica que grita sua existência
através de suas vivências que jamais
cabelo na academia enquanto na latência
os corpos apresentam desgostosos para
além das suas essências já que o sistema
ainda faremos code tratando pobre com
demência achando que somos incapazes de
coexistir anos depois nasce duas
gerações depois a 50 quilômetros daqui
gama love quebrada quente como diz boy
que me toca na levada consciente no
repente que a gente sente as dores de
comunidade esquecido da explosão de
qualquer mente que por vezes não mais
sente as nossas dores preta pobre
consciente e que eu acho mais chato em
toda essa levada não me vê representada
quando a mídia continua e propaga a
idéia de que somos a carne mais barata
foi desse jeito que por muitos anos me
calei guardei toda dor no meu peito e
sem trela como já disse em outros ciclos
e papéis 17 anos esqueci de quem eu era
bloqueei ignorei apaguei a minha era
minha comidinha fé minha essência maré
minas ou minhas ou e anos ou que me
conecto seja com quem for para no
respeito prosear pecularidades que o meu
corpo está a transformar a transtornar
refletir pensar muitas bolhas assim
criei na infância milhares de danças
para mas a cobrança de ser transcenderam
antes do colégio de freira que treta a
certeza a força que de minha luta grita
ancestralidade 35 anos a expectativa de
vida de uma mulher trans ou travesti
brasileira que tenta sobreviver aqui e
ali enquanto 75 anos a expectativa de
uma mulher se sem treta quem que no jogo
da vida vai ser a primeira que em que no
jogo da vida vai ser a primeira a quem
que no jogo da vida vai ser a primeira
o primeiro por isso me recuso desse
jeito no meu luto nem fosse está no
sangue daquelas que um dia de ramadão a
si mesma contra toda a patifaria
transbordou
aaron é mais um fato como diz a paz
necessária donato não adianta passar
pano que o plano rasga qual é passa
desse jeito nós tinha enganado então
apenas reconhecendo privilégios que o
bucks privilegiado conseguir a processar
todos os fatos respeitar nosso espaço
nossa fala para além dos eu falo ou dos
ismos que um dia tentar um subjugar
acharam que o bonde descolonizado não
atiraria contra todo e se falo centrismo
proveniente do capitalismo atirando
argumentos na remada firmamento no
estereótipo desse jeito já que é do meu
peito que a oralidade grita para todo
preto é por nós e para nós que essa
remoção do meu peito por todas as manas
que sofreram assédio no busão não tem
jeito grito contra todas as normativas
contra todos os abusos para continuarmos
seguindo sem guto transmontana ideia
tudo junto o bumbum na levada que conduz
salve salve o meu nome mas a luz mas a
luz que com 12 mas que chega e reluz
representou roller essa entretanto pode
crer diante dessa situação que mata
irmãs e irmãos todo dia eu pergunto será
que passaram acho que não passaram
salve salve meu nome é rosa luz nas
subidas ou descidas da vida se encontra
na internet contra o sistema genocida só
digitar mais um fato barraco da rosa
desse jeito mais um ano
[Aplausos]
[Música]